men and women are not equal I know  everybody wants to think we are but  we're not and that's okay we're Polar  Opposites the man is supposed to be  strong he's supposed to go out and  provide and Conquer and the woman is  supposed to be emotional and soft and  that's okay she's supposed to lean on  the man so that way she can raise the  children better right now there's a  massive war in the family unit they're  trying to flip these beautiful gender  roles so that men and women don't  procreate because if he's all in his  feelings and he's emotional  unfortunately she's going to be repulsed  by him and if she's all masculine and  her male energy he's going to be  repulsed by her and so they start  rejecting each other not producing the  next generation of children so we have  two population easier to control a  nation with less people